dean kramer you see what he's done
looking for his first win of the season
his last three starts he has been really
good only allowing six runs in those
three starts he struck out 11. austin
meadows steps in and he smokes a
fastball by him for strike three
mercedes set up on the inside corner
that's exactly where it's delivered dean
kramer off to a really good start here
in the first two out walk for g-man choi
two outs and here's brandon lau
that's a liner and a fair ball headed to
the base of the wall choi's going to
head to third so lau
jumped on that one and singles toward
the corner two out rally here with
runners on the corners fastball shot
into center hard mullins is there though
in right center he'll put it away as
diaz lines out in the raised strand two
against kramer in the first ridge hill
four the rays making his ninth start of
the season record two and one era 426.
here is trey mancini with two downs
there's a big breaking ball swinging in
this strike three and rich hill
now has over 18 innings in a row of
scoreless baseball second inning no
score joey wendell will lead things off
wendell 292 on the air with three homers
18 knocked in now the o2 pitch breaking
ball lifted in the air to right center
field this is going to go toward the
wall and over the wall joey wendell hits
home run number four and he gives the
raise a one nothing lead here in the
second inning the race have two on with
one out and one in and back to the top
of the order we going randy rosarina
four out of 11 in the series two homers
his pitch drilled back into center
that's gonna carry and it is
out of here
home run on a 2-0 pitch
randy rosarina continues his hot hot
hitting belting another home run that's
number seven
and the rays
break out to a four nothing lead four to
nothing tampa bay lead and the bottom of
the second one on one out better is
freddie galvez 1-0 here's the swing and
he popped him up
starting back now racing in is phillips
he's still coming in slides and did he
make the catch did he yes he did and he
throws the first for the double play so
he misplayed it and then raced in and
made the grab
going into a slide and severino started
to sprint towards second base thinking
it fell in
but the out was called on the catch in
the top of the third runners at the
corners with one away for francisco
mejia one two
mejia he golfs at a curve he sat down
team kramer his third strikeout of the
day two outs and now they're loaded and
the guy you're facing in his last five
at bats has hit three homers and a
double pitched to randy orozorena he
swings it's a ground ball to galvez
scoops the quick throw to second and
they get out of the inning kramer
escapes a jam bottom of the third inning
orioles looking for answers they trail
the raise four nothing pitch to pat
valaka
there's a breaking ball and it's lined
and caught
a little leap by wendell's shortstop so
two up two down now that line drive got
it in
on valencia just a little bit so back to
back two out walks as the first runner
in scoring position today for the
orioles for austin hayes here's a
curveball swung to miss strength three
that's the one he struck out in the
encinium earlier and he just got austin
hayes with the big roundhouse to retire
this side he's allowed three walks but
no hits hill has now reached twenty and
two third consecutive scoreless innings
trey mancini starts the bottom of the
fourth orioles yet to have a base hit
off of rich hill mancini swings and he
skies the ball out towards right field
heading back at the wall a look up and
this one takes a bounce into the stands
trey mancini is on
fire his third home run in two games he
puts the o's on the board four to one
five rbis two homers last night and he
goes deep for the orioles first hit
today orioles trail 4-1 here in the
bottom of the fifth the number nine
hitter for these orioles is reach base
twice this begins the third time through
as cedric mullins comes up to the plate
and a wave and a mess at the curve ball
and there is out number two another
strikeout on that breaking pin mckenna
at first two down breaking ball lifted
the left meadows though hardly has to
move maybe a step back and makes the
catch and that will retire the sides 4-1
tampa bay here in the sixth and on the
corners nobody out let's see if the rays
can expand this lead g-man choi has
walked all three played appearances
there is a ground ball that's gonna go
through the right side for a base hit a
rosarina scores now mckenna overruns it
third base for meadows on the rbi single
by choi and the rays have their fifth
run of the day it's five to one brandon
allows the batter
brandon laos sends a fly ball toward the
corner and left hayes will make the
catch
at the track a tag at third
meadows will score the rays pick up run
number six it's six to one two out
nobody on here in the sixth chill
showing some grit here this afternoon
pitch someone gonna ground it back up
toward the middle ranging to his left
shortstop wendell he's got it throws the
first in time rocco bounces out and that
might be it for rich hill who put
together another
really nice start rich hill accepting
congratulations he's only given up one
earned run in the month of may yeah
pretty good another reigns with a man in
scoring possession and the seventh
phillips at second with one out for
rosarina
up the middle and another base hit
that's gonna score another run how hot
is a rose arena he singles into center
and the reigns now lead
seven to one
boy rosarina driving in four runs in
this game it sure sounded loud it uh at
110. his timing is on and now meadow
swings in this one in the air to the
open space right center field that gets
down for a base hit it heads all the way
to the wall a resorena around third
being waved the throw by galvez is on
the way and up the line all the way to
third goes meadows and it's eight to one
raise
they have blown it open here in the
seventh inning runners on the corners
two down that's a shot the other way
into right field for a base hit so the
parade continues for the raise the rays
with nine runs now in this game the rays
now have 16 hits faces loaded for g-man
choi
whoa there goes the bat second time he's
done that the bat flip with the
strikeout this one he had a little
better distance on
nearly got it to the outfield
down 9-1 in the ninth inning stevie
wilkerson is on the mound oh here to
joey wendell pitch swing and a miss 45
that time he took a little bit off this
is awesome joey wendell wants no part of
this
here's a swing at a drive deep right
field way back and go
it's a two-homer day for joey wendell
and the rays have hit the double digit
mark again it's ten to one tampa bay
did he make the adjustment or did he
make the adjustment ten to one raised
bottom of the night coming all the
orioles are down to their final out of
the series
and it's sky to left
for austin meadows who is there to make
the catch and the rays sweep the
baltimore orioles
winning in a big way in game three
they've won seven straight games and
today they close out this series with an
exclamation point